[Música]
Turquía o Turquía como se le conoce
actualmente entró de manera no oficial
en una campaña electoral todo esto de
Cara a las elecciones presidenciales
islegiales y legislativas que están
pactadas para el 14 de mayo Y quién se
alza como el candidato más fuerte es el
actual presidente resetta giberán quien
tiene un balance con claros y oscuros en
su gestión como mandatario el actual
presidente Turco lleva 20 años en el
poder goza de una racha ganadora de
procesos electorales en total 12
elecciones y tres referendos todos de
ellos de manera consecutiva es el décimo
segundo presidente de la república turca
moderna y está en el poder como lo
decíamos desde el año 2014 cuando
Turquía era un país con régimen
parlamentario también fue Primer
Ministro desde el año 2003 hasta el 2014
también es el actual presidente del
partido de justicia y el desarrollo el
akp por sus siglas en Turco la
convocatoria oficial para estas
elecciones Debería ser realizada el 10
de marzo y de ahí en adelante el consejo
supremo electoral de Turquía se
preparará para estos comicios
inicialmente y por eso decía que era un
llamado a elecciones no oficial debían
ser realizados en junio pero el partido
oficialista advirtió que este mes
coincidía con el verano boreal también
con varios feriados religiosos y por eso
el adelanto de las fechas el 10 de marzo
será entonces la convocatoria oficial
quién podrá entonces medir fuerzas
contra el presidente erdogan un
candidato posible es el alcalde de la
ciudad de Estambul créeme y mamóglu pero
los jueces y los fiscales turcos parecen
estar muy ocupados con este político
para intentar quitarlo del escenario
quitarlo del camino lo van a lograr ya
está sentenciado a dos años de prisión
por diferentes temas que vamos a
analizar a lo largo del programa que hay
entonces de la oposición turca hay una
alianza conformada por seis partidos que
aún no presentado un candidato de manera
oficial entre tanto el partido procurdo
que es la tercera fuerza política más
importante en el parlamento fue excluida
de esta Alianza y se va a postular en
solitario pero todavía no ha dicho quién
va a ser el candidato que aspire a la
presidencia por esa formación Procura
este proceso electoral llega en un
momento en que la inflación es sumamente
alta en Turquía la lida turca que es la
moneda nacional se ha depreciado los
inversionistas extranjeros temen por el
escenario económico del país también
reina el nepotismo y hay cierta fatiga
en torno a la imagen del presidente que
ha logrado eso hay que decirlo
Ha logrado darle una importancia a la
imagen de Turquía en la escena
internacional pero su rol en la Guerra
de Ucrania es bastante ambiguo su
distanciamiento de Europa también la ha
cobrado algunas facturas y su papel en
la guerra en Siria también es
cuestionado por diferentes sectores al
interior del país erdogan tiene
diferentes cartas bajo para lograr
convencer a muchos votantes sobre todo a
más nacionalistas por ejemplo las
discusiones con la otan que son todo un
espectáculo mediático allí en Turquía lo
siguen las cientos de personas cuando el
presidente empieza a contradecir lo que
está pidiendo la otan sobre todo en
torno a la guerra con Ucrania la crisis
de los refugiados ya lo veíamos la
situación en Siria ha llevado a
muchísimos ciudadanos sirios a tratar de
llegar a Europa a través de Turquía
muchos de los sectores más nacionalistas
estarían de acuerdo en empezar a
devolver a muchos de estos refugiados al
territorio sirio y también la influencia
que tiene Turquía en Asia central son
algunos de los temas porque allí
rivaliza con Rusia que es un país con el
que uno no entiende Si es un país Aliado
o un país con el que tiene una relación
cordial o simplemente simplemente trata
de llevar el tema con Moscú por
precisamente la guerra en Ucrania tiene
futuro la reelección de erdogan Qué
papel puede jugar entonces la oposición
tiene la oposición oportunidades de
jugar Al mismo nivel del presidente que
tiene toda la maquinaria del Estado a su
disposición qué balance se puede hacer
de la gestión del presidente a lo largo
de estos años pues son muchas preguntas
y las vamos a analizar aquí en el debate
de France 24 para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a lucíarini ella es
licenciada en etnología es también
docente en estudios de Asia y África y
es doctorante del programa de estudios
islámicos de la universidad libre de
Berlín también está con nosotros Oscar
Martínez él Es doctor en ciencia
política y es profesor de relaciones
internacionales en I University en la
ciudad de Madrid a nuestros televidentes
les recuerdo que ustedes también son
parte de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook y también en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal y la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f-24
todo junto no olviden para terminar que
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
están disponibles en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
de hoy entonces la bienvenida a Lucía
para comenzar este debate Lucía Gracias
por estar con nosotros en el programa
bienvenida y la pregunta de Punto de
partida para este debate es erdogan un
candidato derrotable en las urnas de
cara estas próximas elecciones de mayo
allí en Turquía
Buenas tardes Muchas gracias por la
invitación este iniciamos con la
pregunta más difícil no solamente
podemos especular sobre este punto
la oposición tiene Tal vez un mejor
oportunidad en dos décadas de derrotar
al partido en el poder el antecedente es
la elección anterior en 2019 en donde
perdieron ankara perdieron Estambul Y
esa perder la capital y la capital
económica del país son antecedentes muy
fuertes para dar esperanzas de que si
podrían derrotar al ATP en esta elección
sin embargo la falta de un candidato
declarado hasta ahora es preocupante es
muy difícil especular cuando no se sabe
quién podría estar enfrentando a al
presidente actual
pasó a preguntarle a Oscar también le
doy la bienvenida al programa Gracias
por acompañarnos y la misma pregunta es
cierto gran derrotable en estas urnas
Qué tal Buenas tardes a Santiago Lucía
un placer estar con vosotros bien
Totalmente de acuerdo con Lucía en el
aspecto de que hay muchos factores en
juego y todavía no sabemos muy bien
Hacia dónde va a ir la De qué lado va a
caer la moneda no por un lado si
pensamos En clave interna de Turquía
tenemos
por lo menos dos procesos
judiciales abiertos importantes uno es
contra el alcalde de Estambul y mamoglu
que bueno pues ha sido acusado de un
delito y condenado a dos años y ocho
meses de prisión por un delito tan
ridículo dentro de una democracia como
es llamarle estúpido a los miembros de
la junta electoral con lo cual esto esto
por un lado en Estambul y por otro lado
tenemos el tema Turco que por supuesto
estamos erdogan está intentando
ilegalizar a partido kurdo con
alegaciones de que tiene contactos con
él el partido kurdo terrorista el PK con
lo cual son dos procesos judiciales
importantes dos ases como dices bien a
Santiago en la manga pero que todavía
habrá que ver por un lado el candidato y
por otro lado en los diferentes
desarrollos judiciales Oscar continuó
con usted y le pregunto qué está
esperando entonces la oposición para dar
a conocer los nombres de o el nombre de
esa candidato por lo menos de esa
alianza de seis partidos que yo estaba
mencionando entendemos ya que el llamado
oficial a las elecciones es a partir del
10 de marzo pero desde ya como ustedes
dicen hay varias figuras que se van
perfilando debido a su desempeño
político Pero qué está esperando la
oposición para dar un nombre
bueno seguramente buena pregunta
Santiago seguramente primero están
esperando a ver que ocurre porque el
fallo contra imomóglu en el alcalde de
Estambul es recurrible y el partido de
ha dicho que lo va a recurrir con lo
cual Supongo que estamos esperando los
plazos judiciales no porque empezar una
campaña sin saber si tienes un candidato
o si va a ser posible tenerlo eso por un
lado y luego hay otro candidato que
quizá Viene un poco de tapadillo pero
que tiene bastantes posibilidades que
sea alcalde de ankara el alcalde de
ankara que también se ha demostrado ser
un azote importante para para erdogan y
en principio yo creo que estas son las
dos figuras a tener en cuenta
presidenciablemente hablando y luego por
supuesto las diferentes alianzas este
partido de los seis no que has
mencionado muy bien que no se sabe muy
bien tampoco es una alianza muy
heterogénea y algunos de ellos pactarían
con los kurdos otros no con lo cual hay
mucha incertidumbre Y quizá por eso
también nos gana adelantado las
elecciones pensando en en
desprevenido pillar desprevenido a la
oposición estamos hablando de mansures
el actual alcalde de ankara la capital
turca que del partido republicano del
pueblo también una de esas sorpresas en
las elecciones locales precisamente lo
que mencionaba Lucía fue uno de los
momentos en los que el partido el akp
perdió estos dos puntos importantes
Estambul por ser el centro económico y
principal ciudad del país y ankara que
es el corazón político es la capital de
la República Oscar continuó con usted
porque estamos teniendo un problema con
Lucía con el tema del audio lo vamos a
resolver ya la parte técnica lo está
resolviendo y más adelante vamos a
retomar con ella ella sigue se mantiene
conectada y Va a continuar en el
programa pero mientras tanto sigo
conversando con usted
se puede hablar de una persecución a la
oposición allí en Turquía por el
gobierno del presidente erdogan de
acuerdo a lo que hemos visto a lo largo
de los últimos años de acuerdo también a
a esta forma como se han creado estos
casos que la justicia trata de llevar a
la cárcel al alcalde de Estambul y hay
persecución no solamente buena la
oposición también ciertos militares y
periodistas de diferentes medios de
comunicación
sin duda Santiago Yo creo que es muy
difícil negar que hay una persecución
muy evidente y además una persecución
digamos desde el control que tiene del
poder judicial del señor erdogan Bueno
yo creo que que es la primera vez como
ha dicho Lucía anteriormente es la
primera vez en varias selecciones que en
las que la oposición tiene serias
opciones de Victoria y bueno Y esta
deriva a lo Putin quizás no que está
ocurriendo en Turquía Pues denota que
está nervioso erdogan está nervioso no
cabe la menor duda y parece que la
sociedad civil sobre todo no porque
recordemos que en Turquía Pues hay tres
partes del país principales no la parte
más agraria que central no asiática que
rodea ankara y luego la parte de
Estambul y luego tenemos la región turca
Perdón entonces Bueno hay hay una hay
una serie de
de equilibrios muy complicados y erdogan
trata por todos los medios de defenderse
trata de defenderse lo que es cierto es
que parece que hay una fórmula aquí de
dos aspectos que le ha funcionado al
presidente erdogan y es precisamente
darse legitimidad política a través de
las elecciones lo estaba mencionando yo
12 procesos electorales que ha ganado a
lo largo de su carrera política Pero eso
sí hay unas digamos maniobras que puede
uno decir que son como típicos métodos
de autoritarismo como encarcelar a los
periodistas la persecución a los a las
figuras de la oposición a quienes tilda
de terroristas son parte de ese balance
que vamos a hacer más adelante retomo la
comunicación con Lucía Lucía bienvenida
de nuevo y le hago la misma pregunta que
le estaba haciendo a Oscar porque me
parece importante entender Qué es lo que
está esperando la oposición para dar a
conocer ese candidato que pueda hacerle
contrapeso a erdogan en las elecciones
presidenciales
hay una fuerte división actualmente
dentro de la oposición Y es que hay por
una parte
el sector nacionalista Por qué digamos
el el partido nacionalista el el mhp se
dividió hace unos años y hay una facción
que salió que es el partido II o el
partido bueno que es que sea adherido a
la oposición y ahora va con la alianza
del partido republicano y este partido
nacionalista es por principio anticurdo
entonces la presencia de ese partido en
la alianza opositora implica un
impedimento para una alianza con lo con
el partido kurdo con el Entonces ese
es un problema porque los kurdos
constituyen un sector de la población lo
suficientemente grande como para definir
el curso esta elección
pero
digamos que hay una elección no no se
pueden conciliar estos dos sectores
políticos dentro de Turquía el sector
nacionalista y el sector procurdo
entonces esa esa pugna interna que
errón ya había tratado de conciliar para
favorecerse políticamente entre ellos y
no lo consiguió ahora la están sufriendo
particularmente dentro de la oposición y
la apuesta pues ya fue ir con los
nacionalistas por miedo a ser tildados
de estarse aliando con un partido que
tiene al que se le acusa de tener
relación con la guerrilla kurda con el
pekka el partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán Entonces eso implica perder
muchísimos votos eso implica perder el
apoyo kurdo esa es una de las razones
por las cuales se especula que sería
mejor poner como candidato a
que es étnicamente curdo y aleví como
una manera de negociar Aunque el
presidente del partido republicano no el
no está asociado un partido curdo
entonces esa sería una posible apuesta
para mediar entre estos dos sectores
pero el sector nacionalista del partido
II no está de acuerdo con esa
candidatura y en principio apoyarían a
imao Y mamolo entonces esa es una razón
por la cual Parece ser es difícil otra
especulando es apostarle al elemento
sorpresa No ya sabemos muy bien que
viene Hernán y no sabemos si se puede
destapar un candidato que
pues le cambiaría la jugada al ATP y
frente a ese desconcierto pudieran
pudieran perder ventaja no Lucía con ese
escenario esa división al interior de la
oposición está baraja de candidatos
dependiendo de las políticas que tendrán
que sentarse a negociar para armar una
armar una coalición fuerte de caráctos
comicios cómo lo puede aprovechar
Entonces el presidente aparte de tener
toda la maquinaria del Estado a favor y
su larga trayectoria ya como Primer
Ministro y como presidente y que sabe
cómo funciona el estado Turco al derecho
y al revés que más beneficios puede
sacar el presidente a partir de estas
divisiones en la oposición
siempre una estrategia que le funciona
mucho a Hernán es el DVD y vencerás y
este y hace uso de todos los recursos
que tiene a su alcance el mismo adelanto
de la fecha de la elección no es azaroso
el 14 de mayo es la fecha en la que fue
electo adnan Méndez que fue el primer
bueno Primer Ministro de Turquía que fue
electo después del periodo unipartidista
y este
la referencia o sea Hernán se en muchos
discursos se reconoce como cercano a
esta herencia de Méndez y es la forma en
la que también reivindica un espíritu
democrático frente a lo que él acusa de
sus adversarios del partido republicano
del pueblo que los acusa de ser
golpistas que los acusa de ser
militaristas no entonces el ejemplo es
Méndez que en 1960 fue
este juzgado y y fue este ejecutado no
por una junta militar en el primer golpe
militar en la historia reciente de
Turquía claro entonces esa es la esa
estrategia simbólica mueve muchos
sentimientos que lo sabe aprovechar En
ese sentido no
esa es una manera en la que hace hace
uso recientemente donde está de Esta
división está incrementándola al decir
nosotros somos los demócratas desde
mediados del siglo 20 y ellos son los
golpistas lo cual además se suma a
digamos todo el uso toda la forma en la
que se ha explotado políticamente el
intento de golpe del 2016
entendiendo ya ese panorama a nivel
político de cómo están las bases de la
oposición y también un poco
el oficialismo y entendiendo también
como lo decía yo en la introducción
la situación de la economía que la lira
turca se ha depreciado bastante frente a
otras monedas internacionales y que la
inflación es sumamente alta cómo está el
resto de situaciones del país Óscar es
decir a nivel social hablamos de la
persecución no solamente persecución a
los medios y a la oposición también hay
muchos ciudadanos que han tenido que
dejar el país y es un alto costo que
está pagando la economía turca hay una
fuga de cerebros hacia Europa y hacia
Estados Unidos procedentes de Turquía
Cómo está la situación social de Turquía
al interior de las fronteras del país
pues vamos a ver la situación no es
buena para la sociedad civil y para la
sociedad civil que erdogan como bien ha
comentado Lucía pues ha estado desde el
fallido golpe de 2016 y la consecuente
represión
de erdogan bueno que le dio le dio pues
carta verde para para
esquilmar de alguna manera la sociedad
civil en
Turquía vamos a ver yo creo que erdogan
también juega a unificar a la sociedad
civil dentro de Turquía con el argumento
del enemigo interior no que también ha
jugado igual que el divide vence más y
vencerás que comentaba Lucía no el
enemigo interior y a la vez el
postularse internacionalmente como el
gran defensor de Turquía como este gran
hombre que bueno de alguna manera
representa a este gran país en en Europa
con Rusia mediador durante el conflicto
con lo cual la situación no es buena y
ya te digo que que hay muchas
posibilidades de que si la oposición
juega bien sus cartas pueda ser que
aunque la democracia esté tocada Todavía
queda en algunos resortes democráticos
como las elecciones que que pueden
pueden trastornar
los planes de erdogan Y por qué no
decirlo no Esperemos que así sea y se
puede abrir un nuevo capítulo en la en
la historia de Turquía también con la
relación con Europa por supuesto Y Lucía
su opinión cómo está el interior a la
sociedad turca de Cara a estos comicios
la sociedad turca está muy
dividida tendencias hay algunas
elementos que pueden anticiparse no por
ejemplo que la población alevi suele
estar muy
digamos suele ser voto duro del partido
republicano del pueblo Entonces es
difícil que esa situación cambie Aunque
hubo un intento por reciente por parte
del partido en el poder de atraer
algunos de los alevisas y a su lado
cambiando su estatus el estatus de sus
centros de culto e Incluyendo los
oficialmente como lugares como centros
de culto lo cual les da beneficios en
términos de impuestos una demanda pues
muy larga de de los alevíes pero es muy
difícil que con medidas como estas se
logre cambiar la tendencia y como la
digamos el gobierno cuenta con el
control de los medios principales en el
país entonces de Cara a las elecciones
buscan
construir mucho justo esta imagen del
enemigo interno sobre todo algo que se
ve en la campaña militar contra la
guerra yacurda actualmente
y este algo que también es importante
dentro de ese escenario es siempre leer
muchos de los movimientos de la política
exterior como dirigidos en realidad al
público dentro de Turquía no entonces
ahorita se está moviendo mucho la
discusión sobre las posibilidades de
crecimiento del poder de Turquía dentro
de la otan a partir de si permiten o no
permiten la entrada de betan o no betan
la entrada de Finlandia y Suecia a la
otan por ejemplo no Entonces ese tipo
ese tipo de acciones que parecen ser
política exterior en un contexto
electoral están dirigidos al interior no
Sí en ese en ese contexto Entonces cuál
va a ser ese segmento de la sociedad
turca a la que tanto posición como
erdogan tendrán que hacer foco de Cara a
ganar los votos los nacionalistas los
jóvenes La minoría kurda o no sé los los
refugiados sirios que ya llevan tantos
años en Turquía que a lo mejor muchos ya
tienen la ciudadanía turca pueden votar
allí y también pues por por su pasado en
común algunos tendrán la nacionalidad
por por sus ancestros
cuál cree usted Óscar que va a ser
Entonces ese segmento de la sociedad
definitivo y clave
bueno es complicado saberlo por un lado
erdogan tiene tiene un apoyo muy duro
digamos de las partes Rurales y más
interiores de Turquía más asiáticas esto
hay que mantenerlo y lo mantiene a base
de una apelación al nacionalismo fijaos
que por ejemplo con el asunto de la
entrada de Suecia en la otan mañana
mismo la ministra de asuntos exteriores
de Suecia tenía una visita a Turquía que
ha sido cancelada por Turquía por el
ministro asuntos exteriores turcos con
la excusa de que hubo una manifestación
en Suecia y quemaron un Corán Entonces
es este tipo de movimientos están Están
enfocados para mantener el núcleo duro
del organismo luego no nos olvidemos que
los kurdos tampoco votan todos hacia los
partidos kurdos hay aproximadamente la
mitad un poco más de la mitad de los
kurdos de estos 20 millones
aproximadamente
más de la mitad que vota a los partidos
turcos o al partido Turco con las siglas
que les corresponde en ese momento pero
hay otro 30 40% de estos cursos que
también votan al partido islamista de
erdogan no con lo cual es una cosa muy
complicada nacionalistas luego sí que el
centro izquierda toda la parte de más
moderna de Turquía por supuesto junto
con los jóvenes con los universitarios
pues son una batalla que que erdogan no
tiene ni por qué entrar a cortejarlos
porque sabe que es una batalla perdida
pero yo creo que
los estrategas de erdogan tienen muy
claro que es mantener el núcleo duro
intentar desmovilizar a la izquierda a
través de los procesos judiciales como
la el bloqueo de las cuentas de el
partido kurdo todos estos movimientos
como para promover la apatía política y
que los seguidores de erdogan que son
mucho más fieles y están mucho más
fidelizados pues puedan finalmente la
victoria Hablemos del escenario
internacional lo mencionaba también yo
en la introducción del programa que es
bastante ambiguo a la posición que tiene
Turquía frente al conflicto en Ucrania y
la relación que tiene con Rusia es un
país que se esfuerza mucho por
ganar terreno en Asia central y volverlo
una zona de influencia y allí justamente
Pues compite con con Rusia pero también
sigue coqueteándole a Europa en cierta
forma o de acuerdo a sus conveniencias
sobre todo con el tema de los migrantes
Cómo entender uno y hacer el balance de
lo que ha sido la política exterior de
erdogan a lo largo de estos años y cómo
Esto va a ser importante para esas esas
elecciones Lucía
Muchas gracias Sí yo creo que en su
fuero interno erdogan preferiría mover a
Turquía hacia un escenario euroasiático
de la política internacional
reducir la dependencia de Turquía de sus
alianzas con occidente
pero una cosa es lo que lo que él desee
personalmente que es lo que está más
fuerte en su discurso No ahora sino
desde hace muchos años y otra cosa son
las los intereses prácticos de Turquía y
en ese sentido en este contexto lo que
le ha servido a Turquía es lo que en
inglés le llaman fencity no estar
sentado en el borde como que no se sabe
para qué lado se va a mover entonces han
tenido muchos movimientos ambiguos en
ese sentido no algunos movimientos
favorables a Rusia como declarar que
está que Turquía está dispuesta a seguir
comerciando con Rusia en cualquier
moneda que sea necesaria o en oro y
luego tener digamos reiterar su
compromiso con la otan seguir
discutiendo la posibilidad de la compra
de los aviones f-16 que son importantes
porque actualmente la flota de Turquía
está muy debilitada la flota aérea de
Turquía está muy debilitada Entonces
aunque están exportando drones los
aviones de combates les están faltando
Entonces digamos que en ese sentido
todavía Turquía puede beneficiarse más
de esa postura ambigua que de ninguna
declaración demasiado abierta no de
moverse hacia un lugar o hacia el otro y
en ese sentido creo que la situación Va
a continuar así por lo menos hasta
después de las elecciones pero yo creo
que por tanto tiempo como le sea posible
o usufructuar esa situación Claro porque
por ejemplo vemos Que Turquía ha
recibido a de ciudadanos rusos que han
traído parte de sus fortunas a
territorio Turco la han depositado en
los bancos turcos han invertido allí
están moviendo la economía en cierta
forma pero también Turquía le vende
drones militares a Ucrania para que
combatan a las tropas rusas en la región
del donbas y en el sur de Ucrania en
Oscar me parece interesante analizar
también a modo de balance de la gestión
del presidente erdogan en el año 2018
fue introducido este nuevo sistema
presidencialista Turquía era un régimen
parlamentario él era el Primer Ministro
de Turquía hizo un cambio en en el modo
de gobierno pasó a ser el presidente y
concentrando en la mayor parte del poder
que balance se puede hacer de esa
transformación a un régimen
presidencialista porque varios analistas
decían que justamente Turquía era el
ejemplo de una democracia musulmana para
el área de medio oriente y para varios
países del Golfo
claro bien Bueno pues Santiago vosotros
en Latinoamérica conocéis muy bien los
efectos del presidencialismo no y entre
ellos no decimos en la ciencia política
que uno de una de las grandes
habilidades del presidencialismo una de
las grandes ventajas del
presidencialismo si eres un presidente y
eres un presidente fuerte es que no te
Pueden expulsar del poder por una moción
de censura por un voto de confianza como
pasa en el parlamentarismo que es un
sistema político mucho más fluido y más
dado quizá a la inestabilidad a no ser
que el presidente sea inestable que no
parece el caso no en fin en
Latinoamérica conocéis muy bien el
recurso a los militares para quitar
presidentes que no puedan estar o que no
quieran ser que no quieren que no
quieren que no son queridos por el
pueblo Entonces el presidencialismo es
también llamada una una especie de
democracia autoritaria
y el paso que recordemos no lo ha
inventado él vamos con Putin es el rey
del cambio entre parlamentarismo y el
presidencialismo y es una manera más de
eternizarse en el poder de darle de
retorcer la constitución en una manera
en que él se pueda beneficiar de ella
con lo cual Pues un movimiento un tanto
clásico hacia hacia hacia hacia
el autoritarismo Lucía y su opinión qué
balance se puede hacer de estos años de
presidencialismo en Turquía
mi opinión es muy semejante aquí a la de
mi colega yo creo que evidentemente ese
movimiento se hizo para poder continuar
con Hernán al frente no se ha ido
concentrando el poder en torno a la
figura de roan lo cual es preocupante
incluso para su propio círculo no O sea
sí hay digamos
discusiones dentro del propio café sobre
la el posible deseo de regresar a un
sistema parlamentario porque no queda
muy claro Qué pasaría en un escenario
post Perdón no Entonces ese movimiento
tenía digamos la muy clara intención de
eternizar a Hernán en el poder y de ir
de continuar en este movimiento en donde
se ha ido concentrando el poder en torno
a su entorno a su figura el intento de
golpe fue un contexto que le permitió no
solamente demostrar que el ejército ya
no es un riesgo real para su gobierno
como lo fue para los gobiernos con más
inclinaciones religiosas en décadas
anteriores sino que De paso le sirvió
para controlar al poder judicial que
estaba mucho más dividido políticamente
no y mucho más cerca de el grupo afín a
este clérigo que está en Estados Unidos
fetuló Entonces le permitió retomar el
control del poder judicial y le permitió
demostrar que la dinámica con el
ejército ya no era la misma sin embargo
a nivel del imaginario popular sí se
está utilizando esta idea de que los
golpistas son un riesgo ya no el
ejército propiamente sino los golpistas
Oscar resulta Turquía en la coyuntura
actual y el Perdón un presidente y un
gobierno y un país incómodo para
occidente hablo de la Unión Europea y
para Estados Unidos en el contexto
actual o no lo vio usted así sin duda
sin duda Turquía siempre ha sido no no
tan solo un miembro incómodo de la
comunidad
occidental en tanto en cuanto es un
miembro de la otan sino también un
vecino incómodo de Grecia recordemos el
conflicto con chipre que es uno de los
problemas principales que tiene Turquía
a la hora de
bueno rellenar todos estos capítulos
para ser miembro de la Unión Europea
recordemos también la relación muy
difícil que tiene Alemania con Turquía
con ese gran número de
turcos viviendo en Alemania seis
millones recordemos también como con
erdogan mucho más incómodo por supuesto
No pero de alguna manera no sabemos Qué
hacer con Turquía no casi desde que
acabó la Primera Guerra mundial no y
desistimos el Imperio otomano no se ha
sabido nunca muy bien que hacer con
Turquía no De hecho no no tenemos muy
claro si los turcos Qué clase de gente
son es un pueblo muy especial no No
identificamos tampoco con con los árabes
no entonces Bueno pues es este socio
bastante bastante incómodo y a la vez
interesante No cabe duda a la vez muy
interesante porque es laico tiene una
constitución interesante
es también un ídolo
del republicanismo Occidental con lo
cual estamos un poquito confundidos por
lo menos yo lo estoy no sé si otros
también pero Tal parece que sigue siendo
un país necesario para muchos capítulos
de La coyuntura Internacional sigue
siendo ese puente con el mundo musulmán
con Asia central y también para
entenderse con otros países como por
ejemplo Rusia en este caso finalmente ha
sido el país mediador y ha el territorio
Turco para conversaciones entre Ucrania
y Rusia me queda ya un par de minutos
para finalizar el programa hagamos
entonces las conclusiones Lucía lo que
se viene entonces para esta carrera
electoral que comenzará oficialmente el
10 de marzo qué podemos esperar en las
agendas de los partidos en esta carrera
por la presidencia turca
Bueno antes de pasar a ese punto yo
quisiera decir que sobre la pregunta
anterior que yo también creo que Turquía
es incómodo para Europa porque revela
las partes que oficialmente la política
exterior europea no quiere Mostrar mucho
no O sea utilizar a Turquía como país
tapón para no recibir tantos migrantes
del medio oriente en Guerras en las que
los países europeos tienen un alto grado
de responsabilidad Esas son las partes
oscuras de la política exterior europea
que este Turquía digamos
revela su papel la forma en la que se
vinculan con Turquía las revela y en ese
sentido también es incómodo no Por
quienes son ellos sino porque
rápidamente las conclusiones porque me
quedan 30 segundos de programa por favor
Sí me parece que yo ya dije lo principal
que quería decir sobre los partidos
políticos
lo yo creo que lo que podemos esperar es
que el busque un candidato que
simplemente mantenga su posición
parlamentaria O sea que les permita
tener la los representantes que
necesitan Oscar y rápidamente su
conclusión 20 segundos
a mi conclusión es que sí si la
oposición turca encuentra un buen
candidato y lo nombra con un respaldo
importante dentro de poco tiempo Y es
capaz de argumentar y de montar una
buena campaña creo que hay posibilidades
para que salga del poder Oscar Lucía les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros hoy en el programa ustedes en
nombre de todo el equipo técnico también
Muchas gracias por la sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Luis Fernando Montes y la producción
de invitados a cargo de tanga Herrera
siga con nosotros
[Música]